behörden und mitgliedstaaten
, die
bewertung dieses impfstoffs zu beschleunigen, und die zusage der agentur, eine solide bewertung aller bei der ema eingereichten impfstoffe und therapeutika zu gewährleisten, haben wir auch dr
und
können Ihnen Einzelheiten über die
Bewertung dieses spezifischen Impfstoffs und die Daten zur Verfügung stellen
, die es dem Ausschuss ermöglichten,
den Impfstoff für eine
Marktzulassung zu empfehlen,
und wir haben auch Dr
Sicherheit des Kovit-19-Impfstoffs
und über die Maßnahmen, die
ergriffen werden, um eine kontinuierliche
Überwachung des Impfstoffs
und möglicher Nebenwirkungen zu gewährleisten, solange
er in Europa verwendet wird.
Ich freue mich auch sehr, Dr.
Marco Cavaleri
, dessen Vorsitzender er ist, vorzustellen  emas begehrte
Pandemie-Task Force 19
und kann Ihnen bei
Bedarf weitere technische Details zur Verfügung stellen,
bevor wir beginnen, möchte ich erklären  wie wir
diese pressebriefing durchführen
wollen bitte beachten sie, dass ihr mikrofon
für die dauer der pressebriefing standardmäßig deaktiviert ist
wir werden zuerst kurze anmerkungen von frau
koch dr. ensmann und dr. strauss hören
und danach haben wir 30 minuten für
fragen
nach der frage  und die Antwortsitzung
beginnt, bitte heben Sie Ihre Hand
per Webex. Wenn Sie eine Frage stellen möchten, um
Ihre Hand zu heben, finden Sie ein Symbol
neben Ihrem Namen in der
Teilnehmerliste.
Wenn ich Ihnen das Wort erteile, sehen Sie
eine Aufforderung auf Ihrem Bildschirm  Um die Stummschaltung
aufzuheben würden wir uns freuen, wenn Sie
Ihre Kamera einschalten könnten, wenn Sie
eine Frage stellen. Das
heutige Briefing wird über
youtube und Europe per Satellit übertragen.
Das Filmmaterial kann
von allen Medien kostenlos verwendet
werden. Die entsprechenden Links finden Sie in
der Einladung
da wir nur 45 minuten für das heutige
briefing haben, übergebe
ich jetzt kurzerhand
an emma cook
emma ergreife bitte das
wort vielen dank marianas und gut
Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, ich freue mich, hier zu sein und Ihnen mitteilen zu können, dass der wissenschaftliche Ausschuss der ema heute zusammengetreten ist und eine bedingte Marktzulassung in der EU für den von Biontech und Pfizer entwickelten Impfstoff empfohlen hat. Die Empfehlung
lautet, Cobit 19 bei Personen ab 16 Jahren zu verhindern
Unser wissenschaftliches Gutachten ebnet den Weg für
eine erste
Marktzulassung eines verdeckten 19-
Impfstoffs in der EU
mit den entsprechenden
Sicherheitskontrollen und Verpflichtungen
, gilt gleichzeitig in allen 27 Mitgliedsstaaten
und bietet ihnen eine solide
wissenschaftliche
Grundlage  Die Einführung der
Impfprogramme und ein kontinuierlicher Rahmen für die
Kontrolle und Überwachung der
Impfstoffe ist ein bedeutender Fortschritt in unserem
Kampf gegen diese Pandemie, die
nicht nur in Europa, sondern auf der
ganzen Welt
so vielen Menschen Leid und Not bereitet  wirklich eine historische wissenschaftliche
Errungenschaft
innerhalb von weniger als einem Jahr wird ein
Impfstoff de sein  Entwickelt
und zugelassen gegen eine neue Krankheit
Dies ist das Ergebnis einer beispiellosen
Mobilisierung und des Informationsaustauschs zwischen
Wissenschaftlern, Industrie,
Aufsichtsbehörden, Gesundheitsexperten,
Patientenvertretern
und öffentlichen Gesundheitsbehörden auf der
ganzen Welt
In der Zeit
, in der wir belastbare wissenschaftliche Studien durchführen konnten,
haben wir als Arzneimittelzulassungsbehörden
starke Verbindungen zu unseren Schwesterbehörden in
anderen Regionen der Welt geknüpft
und unter dem Dach der
internationalen Koalition von Arzneimittelzulassungsbehörden
die
globalen Bemühungen zur Rationalisierung der
regulatorischen Anforderungen für Impfstoffe angeführt
entwicklungen, um deren
entwicklung und genehmigung zu erleichtern
heute möchte ich
die enorme und unermüdliche arbeit hinter
den kulissen einer sehr großen anzahl von
experten aus allen
eu-mitgliedsstaaten und meinen kollegen in
der ema, die
am revi beteiligt waren, feiern und anerkennen  Über diesen Impfstoff habe ich
mehrmals gesagt,
dass wir
rund um die Uhr arbeiten. Ich erhalte
zu jeder Tages- und Nachtzeit E-Mails,
und einige unserer Treffen finden
seit dem Ausbruch dieser Pandemie und
des Netzwerks der zuständigen Stellen am Wochenende statt
Behörden in den EU-Mitgliedsstaaten
haben eine
agile Infrastruktur mit einer Pandemie-
Taskforce eingerichtet, der
covet etf, die das beste Fachwissen zusammenbringt
, um eine
schnelle Entscheidungsfindung durch unsere wissenschaftlichen
Ausschüsse und insbesondere
den Ausschuss für Humanarzneimittel zu erleichtern, dem
jetzt der Impfstoff empfohlen wird
und auch  der sicherheitsausschuss der
ausschuss für pharmakovigilanz und risikobewertung
unsere experten traten früh in einen
dialog mit entwicklern ein
und im oktober begann ema damit,
daten zum pfizer biontech-impfstoff in einer so genannten fortlaufenden überprüfung auszuwerten,
einer praxis, bei der
daten auf iterativer basis überprüft
werden  es verfügbar wird, während die
Entwicklung noch läuft
, reichten die Unternehmen dann eine formelle
Markierung ein  Mit dem Zulassungsantrag am
1. Dezember haben unsere Experten
unermüdlich daran gearbeitet, daraus einen robusten,
wissenschaftlich fundierten Konsens zu erzielen, der
vom Beginn der fortlaufenden Überprüfung
bis zum
heutigen endgültigen CHMP in nur 11 Wochen erreicht wurde, die
wir normalerweise
ausgeben würden  ein Jahr oder länger, aber dieser
Zeitrahmen wurde durch die
Größe der Studie
und die Stärke der Beweise erleichtert, aber
auch durch die Reaktionsfähigkeit aller
beteiligten
Wissenschaftler, Experten, Projektmanager
und natürlich des Unternehmens
selbst, aber lassen Sie mich das ganz
klar sagen  wir haben alle schritte unternommen,
um unsere bewertungsprozesse zu beschleunigen die
gewährleistung der impfstoffsicherheit war
unsere oberste priorität
diese impfstoffe werden millionen
von menschen in der eu verabreicht,
und wir sind uns der enormen verantwortung bewusst, die
wir tragen, um diese
empfehlungen für die europäischen bürger richtig umzusetzen
In den letzten Monaten hat ema die
intensiven Debatten erlebt, die in der
Öffentlichkeit stattfanden,
während einige eine forderten  schnellere
Zulassung,
während andere besorgt waren, dass die
Entwicklung zu schnell vorangehe, um die Sicherheit zu gewährleisten, haben
wir bei ema unsere Kontrolle behalten und
uns von der
Stärke der wissenschaftlichen Beweise und nichts
anderem von
unserer Schlussfolgerung leiten lassen, die sich auf die Daten
aus klinischen Studien und mehr stützt  40
000 Teilnehmern und unter Berücksichtigung
zusätzlicher Daten, die
sogar an diesem Wochenende eingegangen sind, ist, dass der
Impfstoff die strengen
EU-Standards für Sicherheit, Wirksamkeit und
Qualität erfüllt
und nach hohen pharmazeutischen
Standards hergestellt wird
der chmp-vorsitzende dr. ensman wird
unsere bewertung ausführlicher erläutern,
aber unsere arbeit hört hier nicht auf. wir werden
weiterhin daten sammeln und analysieren, um sicherzustellen,
dass die verwendung des
impfstoffs immer auf den aktuellsten
nachweisen
der bedingten marktzulassung basiert
sieht einen vereinbarten Plan
mit spezifischen und rechtsverbindlichen
Verpflichtungen vor, um dies sicherzustellen
daten werden weiterhin generiert
und nach der zulassung an die ema übermittelt
es garantiert auch, dass die sicherheit eines
medikaments in der gesamten eu streng überwacht wird dem pharmakovigilanzsystem
die vorsitzende unseres sicherheitsausschusses dr
einschließlich der Schritte zur
verstärkten kontinuierlichen genauen
Überwachung der Sicherheit
, die für alle Cobot-
19-Impfstoffe eingeführt wird
, erkennen wir an, dass Impfstoffe nur dann
im Kampf gegen Cobot 19 helfen werden, wenn die
Bürger genug Vertrauen in unsere
Genehmigung haben, sich impfen zu lassen.
Wir schulden den Bürgern Transparenz  Damit sie
sich auf der Grundlage von Fakten eine Meinung über den Impfstoff bilden können, werden
wir
auf unserer Website ausführliche Informationen
zu den Details unserer Bewertungen veröffentlichen und wir
werden immer darauf hinweisen, dass
wir auch alle
klinischen Daten veröffentlichen werden
, die wir im Rahmen des Antrags bewertet
haben  Ermöglichen Sie eine
weitere unabhängige Prüfung innerhalb der
wissenschaftlichen Gemeinschaft, da
bin ich mir sicher, dass Sie es tun  Wir sind uns bewusst, dass wir
am 11. Dezember eine öffentliche Versammlung organisiert haben
, um der Öffentlichkeit zu erklären, wie wir
Cover 19-Impfstoffe bewerten und überwachen,
und um direkt von den europäischen
Bürgern über ihre Bedürfnisse und Bedenken zu hören.
Die Meinung, die wir heute abgeben, ist ein
erster Schritt, den wir machen  mehr impfstoffe benötigen,
um nicht nur den bedarf
der europäer, sondern aller
unter dieser pandemie leidenden weltbürger zu decken.
wir werden
weiterhin unseren beitrag zur deckung dieses
bedarfs leisten, aber wir haben mit anderen
entwicklern anderer begehrter
19-impfstoffe zusammengearbeitet  auch mit Entwicklern
möglicher Behandlungen, die sich noch
in der Entwicklung befinden, einige
davon werden wahrscheinlich Anfang nächsten Jahres zu ema kommen,
so erfreut ich auch bin, diese
Empfehlung heute bekannt zu geben, wir sind noch nicht an einem
Wendepunkt in dieser Pandemie
, das wird es  Nehmen Sie sich Zeit, um Impfstoffe
in ausreichend
großer Zahl einzuführen, damit alle unsere
Bürger geschützt
und das Auftreten der Infektion verhindert
werden können  Im größtmöglichen Maße bedrückt,
wissen wir jetzt viel mehr über diese Krankheit
als vor 10 Monaten,
sogar mehr als vor drei Monaten,
aber wir sind immer noch
da, es kommen immer noch neue Informationen
herein und diese müssen vollständig bewertet werden,
wie z  die jüngsten Berichte über die neue
Variante und
das sind Fragen,
die im Moment vollständig wissenschaftlich bewertet werden müssen, können wir sagen, dass es
keine Hinweise darauf gibt, dass
der Impfstoff in der Zwischenzeit nicht gegen die
neue Variante des Coronavirus wirken wird
Wir müssen alle unseren Beitrag leisten
, um die Ausbreitung der Krankheit zu verhindern.
Befolgen Sie die
Ratschläge Ihrer Gesundheitsbehörden. Tragen Sie
Masken.
Waschen Sie Ihre Hände und halten Sie Abstand
Dieser erste
Impfstoff ist definitiv ein großer Schritt in
die richtige Richtung
und ein Hinweis darauf, dass
2021 heller sein kann als 2020. Vielen Dank,
vielen Dank, eemer, den ich jetzt geben werde  das
Wort an dr. harald
enzmann den vorsitzenden des chmp herrera bitte [musik] abonnieren [musik] äh äh [musik] äh
[musik]
besser
du